i've already started gaming ken the
episode has started now hello everyone
i'm making a cobblestone generator you
already made one
ah almost died it's fine i don't even
care
all right so we have soul sand magma
blocks but i don't think we need how how
are you so you can beat the ender dragon
in this version because there is
another portal i said this last time
yeah i'm just
reiterating save the episode
it's called a flashback ken i already
know okay you don't gotta tell me
your brain i have been waiting to say
this your brain is not that big
like my brain's so big i have glasses on
right now oh
i have glasses on right now too well in
gamer
yeah in game of course what i'm a small
brain
oh oh did tree glow nope nope they did
not
they're so small still just like your
brain
[Music]
yeah whose brain whose brain that's
right
that's right big brain baby just safe
[ __ ] it is safe we're okay what did you
what did you lose
nothing important everything
time to start over what do you have
i don't have anything
[Music]
okay well you have absolutely nothing no
i put everything away so i wouldn't fall
off
a delicate dirt okay well luckily we
have enough so we can make
one more wooden pickaxe if this fails
play through
over oh god
i turned around you thought you died
again using the water okay
i'm fine i'm chilling water i don't
think it's i don't think it's working
i don't think it burns up anyway
oh this whole episode the whole series
has been me chopping at
a freaking cobblestone generator the the
whole
this is what episode number four episode
four baby
this is the first time we've actually
had a working cobblestone generator at
the start of the episode i think
i think that's worth smashing i can
subscribe heck yeah
heck yeah and i appreciate using hekia
instead of the other bad one
gas ain't monetized
oh thanks bro you're saving life
couples don't generate they're very
dangerous
do not work one of these if you're not
properly trained in cobblestone
generation i appreciate you calling it
that verb instead of bad one well that's
what i call it
exactly okay so now right i think what
we should what we need to do
ken is that we need bone meal okay
where do we get bone meal from skeletors
skeletors
but why why oh why is the treats not
growing seriously they always grow so
fast for me
stuff's on fire why is it on fire oh
what's happening what's on fire what is
this game
the grass i guess oh a tree group
you ate them all last time oh that is a
lie
happy day why would you lie about the
apples dude seriously like that's not
cool
people watch this and they yeah they
will think that i'm lying and then
people watch it they keep up
oh i wonder why the trees didn't grow
it's not like you planted them way
next to each other dumb you're the one
that planted trees
yeah look at me like that
how can you remember yeah how could it
go it happened ages ago come on you
gotta let it go man
it was like three days it was ago
long ago dude i can't even remember i
keep making these skyblock episodes with
you
i hope one day that i'll be i'll be
famous enough that i can actually be in
a thumbnail
no only jack can give views enough
you're not good enough
one day i'll be green pewdiepie i can
put
you want me to put you in as a little
charity option it will do a little
charity i was gonna say that
the video gets less views now i'm so
[Laughter]
i mean look if jack can be in the
thumbnail literally anyone could be in
the thumbnail
oh you hear that jack he's a bad word oh
he says bad words right that's bad word
so the goal is to
get the ender dragon yeah that's the
goal of this playthrough
okay i can't believe you killed one of
the villagers you know what i think we
actually need the villager so just look
away two seconds
all right oh he's back that's so cool
try not to push him off this time
he was here the whole time he was he
just bamboozled his hide behind that
tree
and knocked the tree down he just he
climbed down i'm just thinking
realistically because we need them to
freak right
really yeah to get more now if you give
them food they will they will make babe
this one's this one's locked away he's
not allowed yeah yeah
his pee pee is locked in storage we
don't put this other tree in is this
this work
damn that's all that oh wait over the
over that island there's redstone and
lapras and stuff yeah
so that's all we get that's it damn oh
man this is tough what did you do to the
cobblestone generator
it's i improve it it's better now
like the song better
i'm stuck again my gosh
when we have like everything in this
game like full diamond
full villagers full of hoes we should
still
remember our past we should still
remember the
cobblestone generator
ever what i will never forget that that
that's like i'm scarred for life after
the
refrigerator scarred what what discard
me it means good but
like brain damage i think big brain big
brain damage or small
print i'm not even sure anymore honestly
that must mean big brain damage because
you don't know what is this villager
doing he's just standing on the bridge
looking at me
you're gonna get pushed off um i think
he's charging a toll to pass
i was about to say yeah i think that's
what he said you got a seedy place what
did you do with that
yeah what did you do with that gamer
yeah i planned some food so we don't die
oh yeah yeah i was just gonna say i need
you to you're gonna have to be number
one uh
epic farmer guy i got my hoe i mean i am
from
you hear this accent of course i'm a
farmer
i get the joke because you are speaking
like hillary
how can you build this up so i can't
jump back up
sorry i forgot farmers can't jump high
yeah farmers
they'll get they don't get ups what do
we need right now just like some more
slabs um
i don't know actually i think we're just
good we just we just
is the sun moving it definitely was
night before
yeah yeah yeah there's two suns where's
that the moon
there's two suns listen it's down here
do you not see there's two sons where
there's
one son there's zero sons thank you
what don't waste my time all right don't
worry
don't get trapped under there and die
oh what's out here oh we haven't built
either one of these you think your big
brain because you can tell i'm
dumb no
no oh more tree oh this is a more tree
i'm trying to retrieve as much of the no
no come back come on come back
beep beep beep beep beep what you trying
to get the dirt yeah i think that should
be our goal right
yeah it's probably a good idea yeah are
you going to do like oh you'll be brave
we learn out here we're learning we
learned and we did finally
finally you've watched this series for
how many episodes we're finally figuring
it out
figure things out bruh people are just
screaming
in the comments don't worry big brain i
don't expect
comments to understand big brain
activity that's like giving ein
einstein's theory of relativity to a
monkey
they would be like wow big brain i only
know how to peel banana
concept of time and stuff that's pretty
epic what is your
hillbilly farming tell us uh is that
helpless
i have three dirt free dirt if uh we
have more dirt down
we just need more space so bad guys will
show up and we can kill them and then we
can get stuff we need
all right this is getting more big brain
is that big brain
there uh that's the villager nevermind
not big brain there's a zombie right
here
i misjudged you so this is all the dirt
we get
i haven't thought about that damn one of
the pieces may have fallen off when i
was trying to gather them because
what i didn't drop a single piece how
could you
i doubt that's true damn you're correct
you must be a big brain after all
this whole episode's about question my
big brain i don't know if i appreciate
this
it's not a question about questioning
how dare you question my big brain do
you know who i am
uh no are you the guy in pewdiepie's
thumbnails
no i'm not i have no idea that i
can't help you ah dang it you just gotta
make uh engaging content you i don't
know what to tell you but
you gotta make just get good that's all
you gotta do it's easy
like you shut your face are you saying
i'm not good oh
i'm saying you got a small brain how did
you look
i'm getting stuck look everyone knows if
you want if you want to make it big on
youtube you gotta you gotta appeal to
children
and what better way to appeal to kids
and not have big brain is that why jake
paul is big he has the smallest brain of
all
exactly yeah oh there's 17 dirt in here
big brother
then you compare yourself to jake's
polar crew
like you're you're the equivalent look i
told you that in private okay
i just wanted to know if you want to
make the joke or not
oh yeah well no no it's a good joke i
was telling them that
that i'm basically just like a little
hey you're that guy that plays with
pewdiepie right so if we had like a big
big vlog house i'd be like that one guy
in the background going like oh
yeah wow that's so cool can i be in the
video
give me the thumbnail
[Laughter]
please and then they'll backstab
eventually as well
i hate jake paul he's worse i never
liked you i was just around because i
wanted to be popular
i just want an apple i'm hungry
well i took it from you just told me
some crumbs here man jeez
not asking for luck man you want me to
do some cobblestone you've been diving
i don't know why i like the cobblestone
i felt like you like the camel still
jittery
i have to do like hardcore parkour every
time i come back over here because it's
one block
wait okay you want me to put it another
block
for your brain it's like i have to yeah
yeah yeah thank you oh that
that helps that is a lot of weight off
my my small brain
i'll catch you good skills
that one not that one oh god that one oh
oh it fixed it still
big brown baby fix itself cobblestone
generator number two
nice right there stone generator
stone cobblestone no stone
straight stone baby i think it's working
better now
wow i may be on fire but don't panic ah
what am i doing i just want to get
through i get the dirt yeah
yeah yeah yeah big brain all right i
have 12 more pieces for you you're doing
great oh thanks bros keep it up
probably have to yell right i'm that guy
in the video i just have to yell at
everything
wow there's one more block of dirt
we can get oh oh my god
whoa oh my god this is so lit
fam i love it everywhere i think i
almost got all of that
we're gonna beat the ender dragon ken
it's gonna happen
are we are we gonna beat him well not
with that attitude
what happened to wow yeah we're gonna
beat the ender dragon
whoa never been done before everything
done never been done by two big brains
such as ourselves
there's a spotter over here there's a
what he's in he's it's a spotter he's in
the he's in the crease
a spotter a spider a spider he's coming
he's chasing me
what do i do
okay okay what you do is you say his
food
go down no
you pushed me you pushed me off
this is all your fault how could you
i spent so long
it's okay there's one block of dirt over
here
don't worry maybe that maybe that
villager over there has 12 dirt no i'm
not going anywhere
i have three dirt i have three dirt here
you take them you took such good care of
the other ones
yeah thank you let's go say you could
spawn more but oh shouldn't tell anybody
what you push me off again spawn more
what you want to cheat
[Music]
the date
[Applause]
at least i'm not hungry anymore at least
you're not telling me
it says a lot about our society here
that's all i want to do is eat
that's how you know you're from the
south that's true they said they put
some barbecue out here do they fry
everything in your
is i only i've been to i've been to
alabama and they just fry all the food
everything is frying you're like oh
finally vegetables now they're fried
oh fried vegetables delicious broad
pickles that's close enough
i feel like i've been eating fried stuff
all the time i want to eat something
healthy vegetables please
here you go prada fried okra hmm
that you have oh crap well they had a
gator that's not a vegetable
that's not a vegetable i mean i guess it
is really i thought you meant
for like the animals what like the
killer waves
an orca yeah
we said it in that way or you have had
one of those i'm like no
you ever had some lorca
i think it's a stop i'm sure you we just
go out in the backyard and catch them
catching
killer whale you know no problem you
gotta catch them yourself though just
get
our food next time i come over again
want some orca i did one of the saddest
but most pleasurable meals i had was
turtle
i had turtle soup and i'm like this is
so funny
oh cheryl soup is just like shredder you
don't need bad things
what are you vegan i am pescetarian i
only eat what i kill is there a word for
that
i'm sure there is i don't know it
because never had to know
something like that oh sorry you just
fry everything i forgot
yes right in barbecue is your computer
friday
it's running right now a brain's front
just displays just watching you
just sit down wow look at you go are you
looking doing great you're looking at me
you can't look at me
yeah i'm watching you do it don't mess
up i won't mess up
you know when you do something all the
time but then someone watches you and
you're like
yeah like playing guitar i swear i know
how to play this
i can [ __ ] wait let me track it then
there's like oh god
oh god just stop what do we got here
lapis gold iron
and it's not very generous amount no
it's not very good
that's what they say when you came as
well i was going to put you in the
thumbnail again but now
oh no it's okay the video do better
without me
where's his beard man i don't click who
is it oh my god
jesus i'm not click on this
dude how's that how's our farm going let
me inspect
nothing nothing's happening i need to
check out what you're doing over here
there were some skeletons over there i
thought about killing them but then i
got scared because
they're skeletons man they're undead
this game is scary you think minecraft
is this little kids game
no no oh there's
oh they burn today we got their bones
there's bones
look what i did look at this wow i'm so
cool
so now we're the other villager again
bone meat and then we can put
the bone where's the villager tree
what'd the villager get
[Music]
what did you do i didn't do anything
what did you do
he fought valiantly trying to protect
his love
the skeleton scorch came scourge big bro
hey he took my wheat crash hole he took
mine wet why is it not growing the tree
i put bone meat in it
me squares the need around it to grow
i'm sure the comments won't
count he's back wow he's back he's back
my favorite part about scott
i saw that that was beautiful yeah
that's my favorite part i love that part
my favorite part of skyblock is dying
violently why is this guy following me
he's not following me
it's freaking me out telling me to stop
oh it's one of your fans
oh hey you want selfie just give him a
selfie maybe he'll go away
would you give him hey one selfie no oh
i'll take it i'll take it
i did that yesterday i got recognized i
was in a real hurry so i kind of just
asked hey do you want it
do you want to take a photo no
[Music]
no oh okay cool bye okay
bye so how do we get vents and
if you don't have wool i'm my brain
can't wrap my head around
this well animals and stuff spawn too
but i think they need
room okay we need more dirt i really
didn't either
we're gonna build a house i feel so i
watch there's all these time lapse
episodes of uh skyblock and they build
all this crazy stuff and we're just out
here just
making bridges look around the canyon
it's pretty nuts dude do you see this
cobblestone generator
i see we have three bridges but only one
of them actually go anywhere the other
two haven't made it there yet
you diss my bridges again and see what
happens okay so what should we do then
we're gonna build the house
yeah we're gonna build it at
we don't have any where'd you go yeah
you want a house i could live here
this is good yeah you live in the water
let's just live right here on the edge
just kind of curl up in this little
corner here
yeah i'm pretty much used to this pretty
much have you seen my youtube channel
pretty much usually just living in boxes
in the corner and
getting by okay is it getting bigger
yeah
why don't you just use slab to make the
ground though you big brain
oh water can come back up no i missed it
can you really ow oh there i see i see
i just cut it off to make sure how how
dare
so we have two villagers we have food i
think we're doing pretty good
i'm not gonna yeah i think we're uh
we're about to win this game right now
heck yes um heck yeah so
what's next on the agenda well we could
actually make it to one of these other
islands and see what's out there
build a structure of some kind we could
end it all
i think we should have a platform oh
yeah slaps only i think well you're
making a sword over there
yes oh but first i burned to death
all right all right everybody who wants
to guess that he wants the bat he's
gonna have a cobblestone
glitched
why do you have to die again well i win
i keep being on fire i can't stop being
on fire you're just so high okay here we
go all right
i don't know ah
you dare challenge me
oh i challenge you after this
oh how dare you
i make creepy oh
sort of two fart jokes
[Laughter]
oh breathe
the pain i lost half of my heart
no i am sorry you will not be able to
withstand this
don't be scared
[Laughter]
stuff right here for we have another one
that's for poachers
can't you just make water elevators out
of water you go super fast
can you have so much design i do you can
tell how much progress i've made my own
playthrough
build dr phil that's it the end
i'm done i beat the game oh that's good
enough
how many cobblestones you got i got
seven bra the woman that their box and
i'll go
put them up there someone get that thing
out there all right homie
yeah it's from the south
cars everything you know about the south
is from cars too
[Laughter]
old mater he taught me well
so it's the same right the exact same
question they do in the south
they sure do it's mater in itself
yes definitely ow skeleton shot me and
then killed itself
he just couldn't he couldn't take it i
am in bad mood
i almost died i got sucked into the lava
oh there's another skeleton out there
skeletons bad guys are starting to show
up
that's good and our trees aren't growing
i'm gonna reposition them again
follow me ken this is dangerous
dangerous
i got your back i got a sword here take
take this i have a statement it's okay
this date stick is more powerful oh
thank you pewdiepie touch this
i put you in thumbnails now
my 17 cobblestone
oh no he pushed me
he pushed you get my stuff how could he
get my stuff right what did you get what
stuff did you get my stuff
gave me abs here there's your sword back
i'm coming
ah scared me it even hurt
[Music]
it's like lying you hit like you hit
like a fly
i hit like fly flying why aren't these
trees growing i need more wood
maybe remove the giant cobblestone thing
huh
look okay now you're just now that's big
brain okay that's big brain
oh yeah you finally realized i got a big
brain idea
look now less stuff will hit lava i
improved cobblestone generator
wow
maybe
[Music]
some people make cool stuff like i think
we've done really
quite good i think we've done well yeah
is there any wood
are we out of wood do we drop it all
yeah all the wood gone
supposed to make it check again
wood wow that you look exactly like
ninja
yes i wish someone would pay me a bunch
of money to make sure
guys we have this new service who do we
pay uh my son watches ninja let's pay
him
yeah yeah how much we give 100 million
not too little that plus a contract deal
you're free villager i'm freeing you
from your shackles you're free to
be promiscuous don't push me off
villager i just get revenge
stop it push him this whole episode is
just me looking at this cobblestone
generator
dude i just got another spare block of
dirt
[Music]
what
yeah yeah all right malthus tree group
freestyle three two one go
my name is pewdiepie and i like to not
the hype
his name is ken and he don't know how to
be
gen tall man
he's sad oh
[Music]
my rhymes so hard that he fall off
are you mining are you getting the goods
i'm get i'm so good at minecraft i got
the goods
i gotta see it i think we're rhyming i'm
just speaking enough
oh yeah i went to the island yeah how
you doing this is how we party
we have gravel we can make oh oh oh
get out the water
but why is that all i've become to you
is this the guy you knock off
yeah yes yes it is
just push me off all the time man what's
up with that oh
we haven't made a
sometimes my brain says stop and i
forget what they did we haven't made a
forge yet right that's what you're gonna
say
yeah how impossible how
how you know your brain is so big that
you just have to sometimes stop speaking
it's called a furnace
you're making me laugh huh it's called
furnace how do we get cold though
i guess we can just use wood yeah that
sounds good that's what a great idea
that rhymes
is that what you say it's exactly what i
said
i have 49 cobblestone slab how many do
you have i have none
then i can push them you better get down
49 49 cobblestone please
oh god don't make me fall into lava oh
god
you're crazy you take it too far you
take it too
far there's a skeleton dead out here i
hope we get some bones because i gotta
make them trees grow
hey oh we got some hardware good job
hey wow i run pickaxe oh
double achievements unlocked become
designer
oh my god went from rap and what
what is that this is rap attack
i didn't really listen to southern rip
all right give me the plane
no flame bro apparently not bad luck
bad luck bro what there's diamonds in
minecraft
what what oh a tree grew diamonds in
minecraft okay we have to make sure we
savor this again
this is the only diamond slide we get in
the game after this
nothing actually there's nothing nothing
look at it diamond oh there's several
diamonds here nice
but what there's enough to make one
pickaxe we do make a pickaxe or do we
make a sword to slay the ender dragon
dude
play with fire there i saw you almost
knocked it off the edge
all right we got the we got the goods
yeah let's go
oh yeah let's go yeah i don't know i
think we should save the diamonds
probably
right every time i come back to this
middle area there's just like more
cobblestone
he's like come and put one back every
time you come over here the cobble
cobblestone as we say in sweden
excuse me guy that stands on bridge
excuse me
you pay the toll i said you know who i
am and he let me pass
because he actually didn't know who i
was you're that youtuber in these
thumbnails
you accept the guy you except a guy
what a guy no i'm a merc player
you think you're markiplier seriously
you know the big brand mean is actually
from markiplier is it yeah there's like
a meme where
it's his face and it says it's big brain
i mean i guess it makes sense
but we how can he be big brain if we are
small brain
well they're you know memes are they're
ironic right so
so i'm saying the meme would have to
come from not a big brain
right right yeah
he just
i was appeared sure the water doesn't
leak oh yeah right now these are the
worst
it was growing and now you started it
over it wasn't growing
why you do this it wasn't grinding
neither is these freaking wheat this
these things have been planned forever
and there's no i replanted there
was a couple i played three you have
more trees
you sat on dreams i just got him i yes i
sit on trees is that weird
oh yeah yeah he gets me past him he's
dangerous
he'll push you off i gotta put my stuff
in the box storm to death
you can't starve to that can you you can
die of starvation
yeah bro you never have you never wanted
for food
did you put everything away it's all
safe buddy all right
we have to slap each other to death i
guess we could fish if we
get enough to kill if we kill a spider
no
okay guys if you want more skype
the smash like and subscribe bye bye
what you never played two for simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price